تبقى معنا سيد خليل فقط نذكر بعض الاخبار
العاجله للرئاسه الفلسطينيه تقول نحذر
سلطات الاحتلال من تجاوز الخطوط الحمر
بالاماكن المقدسه التي ستؤدي الى الانفجار
الكبير ايضا عن الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ما
يقوم به الاحتلال من مساس بالمقدسات حرب
شعواء على الشعب الفلسطيني والامه العربيه
قبل ذلك كان هناك تصريحات من الخارجيه
الاردنيه تطالب اسرائيل باخراج شرطتها
وقواتها الخاصه من الحرم القدسي الشريف
وتطالب اسرائيل بوقف انتهاكاتها للقانون
الدولي واجراءات تغيير الوضع التاريخي
والقانوني للقدس وعليها تتحمل المسؤوليه
التبعات الخطيره للتصعيد الذي يقوض جهود
تحقيق التهدئه ووقف العنف حسب الخارجيه
الاردنيه ايضا حذرت اسرائيل من مغبه
التصعيد الخطير وحملتها مسؤوليه ما يلحق
المسجد الاقصى المبارك واعتبرت ان اقتحام
اسرائيل المسجد الاقصى والاعتداء عليه
وعلى المصلين انتهاك صارخ وتصرف مودان
ومرفوض